Lake is with us in Texas hi Blake
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show you how
believe that in eight days
what's up man hey doing everyday right
how can we help so I'm afraid I probably
haven't been maybe the best communicator
with my wife oh we have two young
children it's and Dave I've been
following you for about a year and a
half and it's not as catherine was the
one that purchased me to you you're both
on the christmas i should have realized
you kinda awoke in me are aware of what
you know what is to be financially smart
and now I don't think she's on the same
page for me is trying to be ginza
gazelle incense so when you have $90,000
$90,000 and fifty eight dollars and
seventy five cents in debt and it's Auto
it's a it's a car that I never wanted to
go into at four but I did Chris the old
2002 Chevy Tahoe we had whatever I
justified it and I got a call for the
future so now we have $85,000 income
driving me drive ten thousand dollar car
Kathryn does anyway alright and so on
$85,000 and examine your how old I'm 27
and chapters 25 and how long have you
been married and I do we've been married
for two years we've been together for
sure okay cool so let me tell you what
let me tell you what I did wrong when I
was your age because listening to you
you're you sound like you're a lot like
me once you buy in on something you bit
all the way into the Apple you don't do
anything halfway you go wide open or not
and when you went wide open you went
straight to here's what we are going to
do because you had already gotten why
it's important and you didn't bother to
sit down and talk to her about why this
as you excited instead you got all
excited and ran in and said hey we're
gonna get on a tight budget live live
like like we're broke and we're gonna
sell your car and that's just as really
citing to people when you do that so you
totally screwed up if you're like me on
how you talk to her that's what I would
have done anyway I don't know if you did
that but you didn't talk about the why
you talked about the what and she don't
want to talk to you anymore did I miss
something stop stop you just turn left
stop a man
I said you talk to her about what we're
gonna do not why didn't you yes yes but
I do too I do talk about the white Dave
I do get excited
I do explain to her that I like nice
things as well but I you know we don't
have to have everything right now and I
just feel sometimes with Kathryn in the
way she pinches just good is not good
enough and and you know we're doing good
we're healthy during this coronavirus
I'm working every day and our life
hasn't changed much and I feel like
we're grounded and we're good but the
only thing is that like I'm taking
advantage of the 14-day free trial for
Financial Peace University and I'm
trying to get how to kind of watch with
me and I'm playing it on the laptop and
yes she's like okay I'll watch it with
you we'll instance on her cell phone and
I just you know it's so hard and I
listen to all your shows and it's so
hard to do I stopped dinner together
when I'm doing so John what should he do
he can only control himself Dave and so
number one it tells me they've got a
communication issue that's way bigger
than financial piece yeah and so he
needs to look his wife and hold her
hands look in the eye and say I'm not
connecting with you this matters a lot
to me and you're not looking at it with
me hurts my feelings and I'm gonna guess
there's bigger conversations they need
to have beyond financial peace
absolutely you might want to sit down
talk to your pastor about your marriage
brother absolutely